u.s president joe biden has signed up a
dozen countries to help challenge
chinese dominance in asia during a tour
of the continent he announced the
indo-pacific economic framework saying
it would help the country members to
grow faster and fairer
joe biden launched the indo-pacific
economic framework for prosperity with
the prime ministers of japan and india
while 10 other leaders followed the
meeting online
we're writing the new rules for the 21st
century economy they're going to help
all of our country's economies grow
faster and fair
we'll do that by taking on some of the
most acute challenges that drag down
growth and by maximizing the potential
of our strongest growth engines
the countries joining the trade
initiative include australia brunei
indonesia the philippines and thailand
it's part of washington's efforts to
counter china's economic weight in asia
but it's not a free trade agreement it
doesn't aim to lift customs duties and
trade barriers due to u.s concerns about
the outsourcing of jobs
one goal of the framework is to make
supply chains more resistant for example
to secure supplies of computer chips
which are urgently needed in the auto
and high-tech industries
infrastructure is another key element
there is a massive need for new roads
ports and energy projects in the
indo-pacific region
the biden administration does not want
to lose out to china's belt and road
initiative
in beijing the chinese foreign ministry
said the ipef is an attempt to contain
china and doomed to failure
whatever the name of the regional
cooperation framework it should promote
free trade instead of engaging in
protectionism in disguise
it should contribute to the world
economic recovery rather than
destabilizing the industrial chain it
should promote open cooperation instead
of geopolitical confrontation
the us aims to make the indo-pacific
countries more attractive as
manufacturing hubs members of the new
group are also concerned about china's
increasing assertiveness and welcome the
u.s focusing more attention on the
indo-pacific region
well let's get more on this and across
to our financial correspondent in new
york jens quarter yens we heard that
this crucially is not a free trade
agreement
why isn't it
yeah well i mean first of all it's not
entirely clear what's in it for a member
countries because they do not get better
access to u.s markets or lower tariffs
on the other side when those countries
are dealing together with all the supply
chain issues i mean that could be
beneficial
at least to the united states and also
to some of those countries well if you
look at the last attempt of the
trans-pacific free trade agreement that
the u.s bailed out in 2017 i mean there
had been some criticism from both sides
of the political ielts here in the
united states and now with this very
narrow
advantage that the democratic party has
in congress it isn't really clear if
there would have been any chance to
get a new free trade agreement done
this partnership a large part of it is
about competing with china but actually
markets have been boosted by talk of
president biden potentially lifting some
tariffs on chinese goods trump here at
tariffs i suppose what's the president
thought to be planning
yeah well i mean the u.s president did
mention that once he returns to the
united states um he wants to discuss
this topic with his uh secretary of the
treasury janet um yellen well if you
look at
what is happening here in the united
states with all this inflationary
pressure um the approval ratings of the
president are extremely
low so as i mentioned it is
mostly because of inflation and if you
look at the tariffs that got imposed
under u.s president
donald trump what mostly happened is it
had hardly any effect on imports from
china but it did have a negative
impact on prices paid by u.s consumers
and u.s corporations so that is the main
reason why joe biden is thinking about
dropping those tariffs to lower prices
jen's quarter in new york for us thank
you
you